[Musique]
quelques notes suffisent pour qu'on les
reconnaisse qu on les associés à une
marque et qu'on les ait en tête pour
toute la journée
[Musique]
bon jean gol de pub ça peut changer le
destin de notre pays
l'entreprise en 93 était en faillite
pratiquement mon père a acheté
l'entreprise pour une poignée de change
la stratégie de relance pour le clan
panneton martelé un numéro de téléphone
simple à retenir mais ils ont dû
convaincre l' agence de marketing
leur réaction a été la suivante monsieur
c vous n'allez pas le pire flop
publicitaire au québec
encore aujourd'hui lorsque mes camions
et me chauffeur se promène partout au
québec
à chaque jour mes chauffeurs entendent
déjà leur chanter la fameuse chanson du
clan panneton des musiques de pub
jesse nebinger on a composé des
centaines et elle souvent beaucoup de
contraintes
pas tout à faire ce que tu envisages
comme musique pour pour un spot parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de monde qui vont
décider c'est comme une plus une travail
l'équipe des mélodies qui nous restent
en tête et c'est là tout l'objectif
devrait alléger jean coutu c'est le
principe du verre d'eau
il faut laisser dans la mémoire des gens
des noms des mares des ritournelles des
exactement comme le fait la chanson qui
conduiront bars illégaux
beaucoup parlent les ritournelles
publicitaires sont apparus de
l'invention des radios commerciales et
leur popularité ne s'est jamais démenti
qu'elle soit détournée par des
humoristes
[Musique]
ou reprises par les artistes connus
et finissent par faire partie de la
culture populaire pratt ont réussi ça
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une grosse
victoire ça milite pour le capital
sympathie des marques des verts de rei
pour nous convaincre de croquer dans la
pomme
on a beau connaître la chanson mais ça
fonctionne encore ici mais bien
alexandre chartier à des kamas bas
montréal